[Music]
when people lose control like a tantrum
and start throwing stuff around like
there's a famous scene of I think it's
Steve Ballmer who who lost two of his
main engineers to Google and threw
chairs around in the office or something
that kind of descriptions exist or Nixon
when he lost his position and started
beating the rug and beating his own head
and these Tantrums that people sometimes
throw that usually has to do with
frustrations or loss of power or at
least the threat that their power is
going to be diminished by somebody else
and so it's am very frustrated it's a
tantrum is it's like it's like a
two-year-old basically a grown man who
turned into two-year-olds because they
don't get what they want and and that
happens and that happens in chimpanzees
also that that not only the Tantrums of
kids did they happen all the time
especially at weaning aids when that's
usually for simple ceases at four years
of age the mother starts to push them
away from the nipple and then they throw
enormous tantrums and make an enormous
amount of noise but also in adults and
so adult males will throw these Tantrums
for example when they when they lose
their power so you're the alpha male and
all of a sudden there's a challenger who
doesn't take you seriously anymore and
throws rocks rocks at you and then at
some point if you cannot handle all the
pressure they're gonna throw these
tantrums and and they try to get the
sympathy from the group who then may
support them and they I think they hope
that they will be supported back into
their position although that almost
never happens so that happens and
females may throw tantrums when they
when their relationships are threatened
actually females are not so much into
the power business in the sense that
since their power often depends on on
each and personality there's not much
they can change about that I think and
and they don't just drop from power that
almost never happens so but females have
close relationships and if they have a
fight with a good friend that's where
they become extremely emotional if
have a fight with a rival there's a
female that they don't care about there
very little emotion they're very cool
about that is you know I just beat her
up and and and I don't look back at it
but if it is a good friend that they are
close to and they have a disagreement
with that friend that is very upsetting
clearly and they have a very strong
emotional response to it and they they
very often and almost I've never seen
exceptions to that they very often then
come together and they reconcile and
they make up and stuff like that
[Music]